if Tick Tock really wants an inch  further into YouTube's territory the  answer is not doing horizontal full  screen mode on videos and the answer is  not letting people go longer form on  Tick Tock the answer is monetization  creators Love YouTube because it can  make a lot of money on YouTube as well  as build their brand as well as get an  audience as well as sell their products  and services YouTube will pay you to  make content in 2023 YouTube is bringing  out monetization for shorts this is a  big deal  if Tick Tock wants to compete with  YouTube they need to figure out their  monetization strategy for creators or  creators will leave because they can  make a thousand times more money on  YouTube than they can on tick tock tick  tock get a monetization strategy instead  of worrying about horizontal full screen  mode